oh yeah this is a very sexy woman I'm
Batman you were hesitant in the
beginning to sign on with the project
and then once she became involved and
you had to deal with that wave of
criticism about your casting I mean yeah
were you scared at that point that maybe
this could be the wrong thing no I
wasn't scared about that what generally
works best for me is taking a risk and
that's a real good health thing to do I
think there were a few nights where I
kind of thought I may have pushed it too
far this time but I knew I had Tim and
by that time Jack was in so I really
believed that I could only fall below X
if the whole bottom fell out of this
movie and I work well with my back
against the wall you like that kind of
pressure yeah I like it so a little did
they know that they were just feeding me
baby
hi Bruce Wayne how are you sure talk to
me then Tim about the casting of Michael
Keaton I mean he's not your
quintessential superhero prototype mm-hm
well you know it's the comic book is
based it's the one of the few characters
that's a human being I just found was a
much more interesting way to go I mean
you know there's been a lot of talk
about the size of somebody's jaw but I
mean how often when you meet somebody do
sit there and just stare at his job hold
dinner you know and whatever title you
don't you know that's a very I'd say 1%
of the whole thing with Michael you just
get so much more and you know all you'd
have to do is look at him and you see
him putting on a bat suit and it makes a
lot of sense as opposed to you know some
big strong rich handsome guy I mean I
could never figure out why a guy like
that would want to put on a bat suit
well I mean let's face it you're not
exactly normal everybody of course has
their way that they relate to the Batman
character for a lot of women it's a
sexual thing oh yeah this is very sexy
movie what's your take on that when you
had the suit on
it's a very sexy movie well Kim Basinger
has said that when you know when you had
the cape and the mask and everything on
that it it did something to her I think
the whole look of this guy put in this
atmosphere you know it's a sexy movie
regardless I really think I'm not I'm
not being humble here I didn't design a
suit so I can't take any credit for it
except that it is an awesome thing my
life is really complex Michael will you
at all I don't know maybe hurt is the
right word did you feel like why do I
have to prove myself to this faction of
Batman fans
well I fortunately I wasn't aware that
there was this faction of the DC Comics
fundamentalists as I call them and what
by the time I by the time I discovered
that they had such a heavy Lobby we were
in England working so that was really
fortunate for us because it was then I
came back and then I got it about nine
minutes after I stepped off the plane I
started I noticed something was afoot
about that time I was pretty fascinated
by it and I still am pretty amazed by I
just don't quite get it I mean you know
what are we talking about here any words
it's a movie you said at one point that
being a movie star would be pretty neat
stuff that you thought it would be okay
now that you're you've crossed that
barrier into becoming a movie star and
you've got some of the baggage that goes
along with it
is it still neat what I find interesting
is from an objective point of view is I
think there are really good actors and I
think there are really good movie stars
and then there's a group that crossover
but for my money there aren't many who
make do both well and I don't take one
away from from the other you know what I
mean so I've never I never went into it
to be to become a movie star and anybody
who tells you it's not fun to have
people say hi to you and say they think
they're great or lying to you
hit a guy with glasses on would you and
you get to share the screen with Jack
McCall man you kidding me it's great
it's just great as good as it gets but
Tim Kim and Jack into that combination
in a movie is this potent I like him
already
[Laughter]
[Music]